and uh thank you for joining my session
my name is mikhail brigiden i run a
security department at pgs software but
also i'm a white hot security researcher
and today i want to
share my
findings with you so that you can fix it
in your projects
and
i want to
show you how a small
vulnerabilities may lead to a full cloud
account take over
let's start with something simple html
how to hack your cloud using html
that's very simple
just look at the source code and uh
i don't know why but
there are many many cases in which
people just
hard code
credentials to their cloud in a source
code either in
javascript or like like here
in a comment for
someone to remove later
but
why do you hard code it if you want it
to be removed instead of putting it
somewhere in a documentation
so we have this source code and this
scenario is
really simple because we just extracted
valid aws credentials from the source
code and hey these were admin
credentials because someone
don't know how to
configure their users cloud users
and
what went wrong here
first of all
sensitive data in a source code
there are many different ways to share
a part of documentation with your team
you don't have to hard code it in
in in your source code
you can just put it on confluence or
somewhere else if you want to say that
there is a
set of credentials to use on there on
the non-product on dev environment
something like that
now uh let's move to something more
complicated kubernetes who knows
kubernetes who is using kubernetes
nice
and uh how to hack your cloud
using kubernetes
it all starts with kubernetes api
like phil mentioned on his presentation
before there are many built-in security
features and developers
uh i don't know why but uh want to
disable these features and uh like here
there are many kubernetes apis available
publicly in public subnets with public
ips and role-based access control for
them is disabled this means that anyone
can just connect to that api and ask for
anything like secrets like config maps
like a list of
pods with the configuration
secrets are only base64 encoded so it's
quite easy to decode them
and
if you ask
correctly you can get something like
that a list of pods uh with uh a time
how how long they are running what state
they are in config maps so the content
maps are just a configuration files
that are later pushed to
containers
and secrets simple secrets username
password
etc you can you can see that we already
have
s3 access
the secret key
on
on the secrets list so this is our first
uh
this is this is our first way into the
cloud
but it's only s3 access s3 services uh
it's used to store files on aws cloud
flat files
you can extract something interesting
from these files okay but we are
aiming for more
so uh what else i was able to extract
from one of these
kubernetes
secrets
jenkins admin credentials
jenkins is the automation server that
you use to run your jobs to build
something and
there were credentials for admin user so
in the next step
i was trying to find a way to log into
that jenkins app and there are two ways
to log in first of all you can find a
public
public endpoint for that jenkins like
jenkins.example.com
and then using these credentials you can
log in but sometimes companies hide
these
these tools like development tools and
there is no way to access them
from the internet but you already have
access to kubernetes cluster that
runs this jenkins so you can easily
forward port 8080 of that
jenkins
app jenkins pod to your local host and
then you just simply open your browser
and go to localhost and on port 8080 and
that's the same jenkins application so
you can log into that jenkins
application but
what then
first of all uh as admin you have access
everywhere you can start digging
in workspaces if your job runs at least
once
there is a source code for that job uh
for of the from the repository that the
that job
depends on and that source code is there
available for you so you can just see if
there are any hard-coded credentials or
something that
you may use to dig deeper
in my scenario there was a config file
with another pair of
access keys for aws this time i got
access to sqsq and lampdas and other
services but still not enough
then
second place in jenkins it was in
jenkins credentials
service
if you use jenkins you know that you can
store your credentials in jenkins
credentials but if you have more access
to jenkins you also know that you can
easily decode all these credentials so i
just
took a look at the credentials list and
found a
github or gitlab credentials there so
after the coding
i had access to all repositories of that
company
but
also
i still didn't have access to full admin
account on on aws
so the next step was to check
build logs console logs from different
projects on jenkins and in one of these
jobs
i noticed
api calls for
for aws
using aws cli this means that
the pod that
runs this job has access to aws either
uh
on
using hard-coded credentials or using a
role
so
i used cubectl exec to run bash on that
pod
and uh thanks to that i i was able to
run any command and this pod had
iam roll aws iam role with admin access
policy attached and that was what i
wanted to achieve admin access on that
account
but what went wrong here first of all
public resources why kubernetes apis are
public i have no idea
these are not endpoints that should be
accessible
by customers by your end customers so
if it's not
something interesting for your customers
but just for developers just hide it
hide it behind behind a vpn if there is
a security feature use it
also
usually
your production environments are covered
by penetration tests but
many companies decide to
exclude non-profit environments from
pentests
to lower the bill for for this
penetration test and
these
nonprofit environments
are
exposed and sometimes vulnerable
also
risky design
maybe it's not that
we don't know that it's public maybe we
decided to make it public because
we are a startup we just started to
develop anything and we don't have vpn
it costs so
let's just make it public and
hope nobody finds it
and
then what else went wrong
security features if there is a role
base
access control
enabled by default just use it if you
want to disable it okay but why
and sometimes uh
the responses were
okay but it's our cluster it's a random
ip who knows our random ip it's only for
our team to use
and nope it's not there are many search
engines
that
scans the whole internet all ips and all
ports on these ips and
they record responses they record
banners from from these ports and when
you create a new
new resource on the internet with new ip
it will be scanned in two minutes so
after three minutes i will have access
to it without making any noise in your
infrastructure because i will know that
you have something vulnerable vulnerable
and i can hit you right there
and uh
what else uh encryption if there is a
way to
encrypt sensitive data just do it and
don't forget that base64 is not an
encryption
and
yeah so
if you
have to store your sensitive information
in
tools other than password managers or
secret managers be sure that they are
these are encrypted that way if i get
access to for example kubernetes secrets
i don't get access to plain text
credential credentials but
ciphertext and i will not be able to
decrypt it easily
or i will be i will show you later
and then uh firewalls same as before we
have developers everywhere different
countries and
we are poor we don't have vpn
we just want them to work for us and
that's why everything is
in public why not
okay and then principle of least
privilege a very very common scenario
every single developer is admin in our
tools because maybe one day they will
need to do something more than just
doing what they are usually doing so
yeah let
let's give them admin access for
everything
because then they will not
need to contact us for
for higher
higher permissions
then we have our cicd tools we have
these tools that we use to build our
cloud so these tools have full access to
our cloud they can create resources they
can manage resources and delete
resources that's okay
but
then why do we give admin access
to these tools for our developers if
they are admins on our tool that is
admin on our cloud hey what's the
problem to deploy malicious resources
and
get the same access level so uh
yeah if if you have a tool with higher
permission
permissions just be sure that your
developers cannot exploit this tool
and uh yeah last but not least uh
running apps as a root user because yeah
my app sometimes uh
needs access to different uh different
places and uh
it's it's easier to just give it a
root user instead of setting correct
permissions
but when i get access to that app i am
also
doing anything as a route there so i can
install new
new library i can install new app i can
get access to every single piece of
information on that machine thank you
then we are ready for the next uh for
the next scenario
symphony profiler who knows symphony who
works on symphony
okay
symphony is a php framework it's a a
really good framework with different
versions and every single version is
vulnerable in its own way
and profiler is a development tool used
by
php developers to see what's going on
with their app usually it's turned on on
non-pro environments and you can see
different
different parameters of your application
you can see what's going on there for
example
you can check
server parameters environment variables
used by the application but you can also
check all
requests and uh parameters of all
requests that
that your users are
making in this application
this includes
login
requests with
login post login request with uh
username and password
and some versions of symfony also allows
you to
open uh any file in a project structure
this can be parameters yaml file with
all your other configs not available in
server parameters on environment
variables
but let's stick to
to our request history
but first this is how it looks like if
you
open the provider tool you can see that
there are some environment variables
and we have our aws keys already there
but these keys only
allow you to access s3 again but then
i found a
post request to a login endpoint with
plain text login and password okay let's
use it
when i use that
there are of course there's an endpoint
defined for this uh for this request i
know where this request was made and i
was able to reuse the login and password
to log into that internal application of
that company
it was uh admin account because who else
is using nonprotein environments
non-profit apps
and uh it was of course uh
dev environment okay but dev environment
had a dev
a subdomain so instead of going to
dev.example.com
i decided to use to example.com and use
the same login and password and guess
what it worked
so i was in it was internal application
custom internal application different
features there and there was a
single sign-on page with different
apps available for that user
there was a crm
there was
webmail
so
i didn't need to
access any customer data so i decided to
use the webmail to see what's there
on this webmail i found a lot of aws
related emails like invoices like
trusted advisor reports
and uh
this
made me thinking that maybe this is a
root user email for that aws account why
not let's check that i tried to log in
using that email and
i didn't have password but i have access
to that inbox so why don't you use
rested password functionality
and
guess what it worked
i got my new password by clicking on the
link that i got on that email and i was
in
why because there was no mfa so just
login password and you're in
and this was really aws root user so
i had full access to that account there
was no mfa
etc but
that wasn't
the only
nice thing there it was the
account used for the whole organization
it was organizational management account
so instead of getting access to one
account i got access to
40 or 50 different aws accounts on admin
level because this
route account
was a trusted account for
admin roles on all other accounts
yeah why not
so what went wrong here
first of all production data on a
non-production environment
it's a common scenario where a customer
asks
developers to
[Music]
find
to find a bug somewhere and they just
copy
copy the production database to a
nonprofit to work on a non-profit on the
production data but
it's not a good idea because then first
of all
you break many many rules
gdpr doesn't like you etc but
you also
have your production data on the
non-profit which is not that secure
because you excluded it from pen tests
and if i get to a non-pro then i can
simply using the same credentials get to
prod
so this is the second point here
reusing
passwords for the same users on
different environments even if you don't
copy the whole database
you want to
remember the same password single
password for all environments in this
app and the word remember
is underlined here because if you
remember your password is already bad
instead of remembering it just keep it
in the password manager
but
if you have many different environments
your app runs on different environments
be sure to use different passwords on
each environment that way if one leaks
it will only expose this environment and
not non
not the prod one
and
sometimes
i also found
different architectures where prod and
non-prod were running on the same cloud
okay it's easier to manage and
for small companies it's better to have
one account
that's how they
were explaining themselves but
when you have both on single account and
you have your non-profit not that secure
then getting into that account means
that
someone gets into your account with pro
data that's not good
and uh
sharing email for different uh
for different services
when i found this uh webmail it was not
only for aws but
other services were also registered on
that email and it was
office 365 administration account it was
a github organization main account
because they wanted to have everything
in a single place to manage everything
from a single place and thanks to that i
got access to every single place
and also
sometimes companies
try to
explain themselves that
this account is being used by different
uh
different team members and
if someone goes on vacation we want to
be sure that others also have access to
that but hey have you heard about
distribution list instead of a
single inbox for that maybe you can use
a different uh
you can use different uh
emails
for different services but then they can
all point to one
distribution list where you have your
team members
underneath
and uh also uh
also it's a good idea to change your
password from time to time because if it
deletes today it will not be valid uh in
three three to six months depends on
your policy
and uh use mfa wherever possible why
because if your password leaks
then
i will try to use it and if you have
mfi enabled then it will be a bit harder
for me to use it a bit harder because
as one of the
evil hackers group
showed us recently it's also
not impossible to bypass mfa by for
example
finding
where the guy whose password we go to
where where he lives and
we know that he lives for example in
poland and we know that now in poland
there's 2 a.m
at night and we will just push a lot of
a lot of mfa requests to his phone
and uh if it's not
on silent mode it will pink and pink and
pink and pink and finally he decides to
press ok allow and that's how they
bypassed a lot of
mfa
multi-factor authentications just
because they bombed the mfa
also sometimes
teams decide not to
enable mfa because the account
is being used by
many people it's it's a third account
and that's a red light if it's a shard
account just
don't do that and create dedicated
dedicated accounts for your developers
now
the last one
the last scenario it starts from github
who uses github
who uses public repositories on github
okay let's start there
public github repositories
this this can be the only step here
because if you
look for
different credentials you can just get a
lot of results with different
credentials not only aws
but
many different clouds and you can just
find it grab it and use it
but let's make it
a bit
more interesting so
for this scenario i found the repository
with
interesting variable names but
the values for these variables were
encrypted
wow
someone used encryption in that in their
hard coded
credentials in the file in repository
okay
so i decided to dig deeper into that
repository to find a way to decrypt them
and then i found a java class
with the whole
decryption logic
okay still
not that bad because you need a
a secret key to decrypt it but it was
hardcoded in the decryption class
because it's easier it's the only place
where it's used so yeah why not
so i was able to
decode these credentials and i got
access to office 365 account
here we can see different different
examples of what to extract from
public repositories
you can see
different credentials
for smtp for
databases yeah whatever you want just
pick one
and
then how to how to proceed with that we
have access to office 365 account
and
using that you can see what
what subscriptions are or what plans are
available for that user and this user
had all plans available so for example
there was a team space api available and
this means that you can log in using
that credentials to teams
and on teams you can just find a c
levels for example ceo and say hi
and this accounts these accounts are
usually service accounts so the ceo will
get a message from no reply at
mycompany.com okay hi
but that's not what we are looking for
we want to get access to
cloud accounts so other cloud cloud
accounts
so instead of just saying hello to a ceo
i decided to
open sharepoint
and on sharepoint
i got access to many different
files
and one of these files was a pdf file
and this pdf file was called a jira
installation guide or something like
that it was a step-by-step
configuration guide
that was created by some juniors
to
document what they were doing step by
step to install the jira new jira for
the company and the last step was and
now we created admin user with login and
password
okay thank you
so uh i got a login password for admin
user on jira
and jira usually
it is a public service so jira
jira.example.com and voila there was a
login page for that thank you
and i was able to login to that jira and
as admin i can access everything so
i looked for interesting projects
a few with aws
in name and one of these projects had
tasks to create iam user for
external service it was a vulnerability
scanner or something like that
and uh this task had a comment and in
this comment
it was uh
access and secret key in plain text
someone
someone finished that task by posting
these credentials in a comment
so
yeah thank you i just grabbed this uh
the credentials and i'm admin on your
cloud
what doing what went wrong here
first of all
do not hard code any sensitive data into
your source code there are other better
ways to store passwords to store keys
you don't have to
put them in your config files stored
next to your classes etc
and
if you say that you don't use any secret
management tools secret managers
password managers etc just start do it
start doing it because you need it
it's a bit safer
and
if you encrypt something
be sure to
keep the encryption key the secret key
secure and do not put it just next to
the logic because then there is no logic
in that
and uh
when
you
push something to the repository and you
know that oh i shouldn't do that
it's okay it's too late
then it's not enough just to overwrite
it with
with a new new version with some dummy
value because it's git it's version
control you can return to previous
version you can check git history and
guess what it's there
so instead of just overwriting it be
sure that
your credentials are rotated password is
changed key is invalidated and
it will not give any access to someone
who finds it
then
we have bot tools selection
for this public github repository it was
a
support team working on
jira tickets they decided to
create
some script that will reply to any new
ticket in 10 minutes because
they had a sla that they have to reply
to every single ticket in 10 minutes so
instead of doing it manually they
decided to automate it okay that's a
great idea but
as they were not developers they didn't
know how developers work and where they
store their
code so they created a free public
repository and pushed everything there
and
also
if you
don't know how to share credentials in a
secure way for example sharing it from
your password manager
and but you need to share your
credentials because there is a new team
member and you just created the account
for him
it's not a good idea to share both login
and password on the same channel for
example on teams or on slack why
imagine a situation where
your new team member shares his screen
right now because he presents something
to a
customer or to
other people from different projects and
uh instead of sharing just the single uh
application window he's sharing the
whole screen but uh he'll he only
only shows what's there on part of the
screen on one of the applications and
then on the rest of the screen there's a
slack in in background oops sorry
there's a slag in background and
when he's doing his presentation
you just send him the login and password
and it's there
anyone
on that call can just grab this and copy
this and try to use it while he is
presenting
something
so instead of doing that
send one thing on teams one thing on
email or if you really need to use only
a single channel
you can use a tool like a one time
that's a
web tool where you generate a one-time
link with your secret uh phrase
and uh be sure that the person you are
sharing it with uh is focused on what
you will just
what we will send to him just right now
and send the login and the link
then he clicks the link he gets the
secret value
moves it to password manager and if
anyone clicks the link again or copies
that the link open in their window it
will be invalid because it's one time
link
and uh then we have uh
lack of security awareness that's the
biggest problem everywhere because
usually developers don't know that
something bad may happen if they use it
that way or in other so
not only developers but in this case
we had a
support team
who had access to our aws
account to create a new user and then
they just decided to
post this uh accessing secret key as a
comment uh
in uh
in this in this ticket okay this was
okay from their perspective because the
ticket was done
we can move to another one but it
can be done a bit better instead of
doing that they can share it in a secure
way because
the place that they decided to to use
can be
opened by not only the
the guy who created this ticket but all
other team members who have access to
the same
same project
also
if you
create documentation
it's not a good idea to
put valid
user credentials into the in this
documentation because that's not
not required it's not needed to to be
there and i asked them why they did that
and
they said that
we were told to document every single
step and that was one of the steps so we
documented it
okay that's a nice explanation but still
you can think before doing something
that may be risky
and uh
last thing here
if you really have to send emails from
your application there are better ways
than using your own
your own
directory user credentials because if
you use your own office 365 login and
password just to send emails
then anyone with access to that
repository will get your login and
password and they can log in
as you to to this service and here it
was office 365 but it can be any other
mailing service and uh that's not really
what you
want
that was the last slide
thank you for uh for joining this
session maybe you have questions that's
the right time to
ask you were talking about a scenario
where you managed to get the access to
the white mail
and when you went through the password
sorry
you obviously have access to
how long it took the company to actually
realize
okay the question is uh how long it took
the company to realize that i changed
the password for a cloud account
the thing is that
when i find something i report it to the
data owner it's not like i want to
dig into your cloud account and then
just maybe publish it or move on i do it
to uh
to find a way in and then to tell the
company hey you have a problem there's a
hole so i told them immediately that
when this was possible at the same the
same night i shared
the report with them saying that hey you
have a big hole here and the password is
changed so i don't know how long it
would take but
there are other cases where i am
completely ignored by by these companies
so uh i still have valid
access to different uh cloud accounts
that i found uh
in june or july
still they're still working so yeah
would you suggest that this ship is like
some sort of alerts
oh yeah alerts um now the question is if
they should use some some kind of alerts
uh yes and uh for example uh the the
scenario with kubernetes
you don't usually want your developers
to login to these containers and you
don't want them to be there because they
have everything streamed to the cloud
logs are in different place so if
something appears in
bash history or ssh log
then you can get a notification that
something bad is going on because
usually they shouldn't do that
also
if you use
guard duty on aws it can scan
your logs your api calls on aws and it
can
find a weird behavior because uh
i here in my scenario
i logged into jenkins machine to
communicate with the cloud and this was
okay from the perspective of guard duty
because i was i was still on that
machine but it's possible to extract a
temporary access secret key from that
machine and run it from my laptop and
then uh this
this will be successful as well but
it will be marked as uh something weird
in guard duty so you will get your
notification that
ec2 credentials were used outside of the
ec2
and you can have automating automated
responses to that to block this this
role to remove that that access etc
if you have other questions you can
reach me on linkedin
i will
try to
answer
every single one of your questions
future questions
thank you
[Applause]
you